en muchas ocasiones hemos visto que la
distancia es igual a rapidez
multiplicada por tiempo y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es usar esta simple
fórmula esta simple ecuación para
entender que las unidades pueden verse
también como objetos algebraicos pueden
ser tratadas como variables a medida que
estamos desarrollando una fórmula una
ecuación lo cual llega a ser muy útil
para asegurarnos que al aplicar la
fórmula estamos obteniendo las unidades
que realmente corresponden así por
ejemplo si nos dan una rapidez de 5
metros por segundo si nos dan una
rapidez de 5 metros por segundo y un
tiempo de 10 segundos podemos aplicar
directamente la fórmula para obtener
entonces que la distancia es igual a la
rapidez 5 metros por segundo
multiplicada por el tiempo que es
segundos lo interesante aquí es que
podemos tratar las unidades como si
fueran objetos algebraicos como si
fueran variables así es que esto va a
ser igual a aquí tenemos una
multiplicación ya sabemos que el orden
de los factores no altera el producto
por lo que esto es igual a 5 por 10 5
por 10 que multiplica a metros por
segundo y multiplicado por segundos y
como hemos dicho se pueden tratar las
unidades como si fueran variables aquí
tenemos segundos entre segundos o
segundos en el denominador multiplicados
por segundos en el numerador que se
pueden cancelar aquí tenemos 5 por 10
que por supuesto es 50 5 por 10 50 así
es que esto es igual a 50 y las unidades
que nos quedan son metros 50 metros y
eso está perfecto cuando tratamos las
unidades como objetos algebraicos
pudimos simplificar las y funcionó pues
obtuvimos que esta distancia está en
metros la cual efectivamente es una
unidad de distancia de aquí podrías
decir eso está maravilloso pero
qué complicarse tanto cuando estamos
aplicando una simple fórmula como esta
pero lo que quiero mostrarte es que esto
que hice con esta fórmula tan simple de
distancia es igual a rapidez por tiempo
es algo que puede ser sumamente útil
esto que hemos hecho aquí se llama
análisis dimensional y así como es útil
para fórmulas tan simples como distancia
igual la rapidez por tiempo puede ser
muy útil para fórmulas más complicadas
que aparecen en física química e
ingeniería de tal manera que cuando
aplicas el análisis dimensional a dichas
fórmulas de cercio las matemáticamente
de que estás obteniendo un resultado con
las unidades adecuadas pero aún con esta
fórmula podemos hacer un ejemplo más
complicado supongamos que la rapidez es
igual a vamos a mantener la misma
rapidez 5 metros por segundo pero
supongamos que el tiempo lo tenemos
ahora en horas en lugar de segundos
digamos que en esta ocasión el tiempo es
igual a una hora aplicamos entonces la
fórmula tenemos que la distancia es
igual a rapidez que es
5 metros por segundo por el tiempo que
es una hora y esto es igual
multiplicamos 5 por 1 multiplicamos 5
por 1 y nos da 5 y ahora tratando las
unidades al que prácticamente vamos a
hacer el análisis dimensional así es que
tenemos 5 metros por segundo
multiplicados por ahora o podríamos
decir 5 metros ahora por segundo pero
ahora esta no parece una unidad de
distancia por lo menos no una unidad de
distancia de las que estamos
acostumbrados a manejar queremos
simplificar esto de alguna manera aquí
podemos darnos cuenta que si estas horas
las pudiéramos expresar de alguna manera
en segundos entonces se podrían cancelar
los segundos para obtener metros la cual
es una unidad de distancia a la que
estamos acostumbrados para esto vamos a
multiplicar la expresión por un término
que tenga horas en el denominador
segundos en el numerador lo que
podríamos llamar segundos por hora y
cuántos segundos hay en un ahora bien
hay 3600 voy a hacerlo con otro color
3600 segundos por hora esto también lo
podemos escribir como hay 3600 segundos
en una hora y al multiplicar que nos
queda bien aquí tenemos que se cancelan
estas horas con estas horas estos
segundos con estos segundos y nos va a
quedar entonces al final de cuentas el
producto de cinco por 3600 que es veamos
cinco por tres mil son 15 mil 5 por 600
son 3 mil 15.000 más 3.000 esto nos da
18 mil y la única unidad que nos queda
son metros
así es que 18 mil no éstos no son 18 mil
18 mil horas y 18 mil
metros y ya la tenemos ya tenemos la
distancia expresada en unidades que
conocemos si viajas a 5 metros por
segundo durante una hora vas a recorrer
18 mil metros pero sigamos
ejercitándonos en el análisis
dimensional suponte que ahora queremos
expresar esta distancia en kilómetros
cómo le hacemos bien si tenemos los
18.000 metros los 18.000 metros y los
multiplicamos por algo que tenga metros
en el denominador
y km en el numerador se cancelan los
metros y ya vamos a obtener nuestro
resultado en kilómetros y aquí queremos
multiplicar por algo que no altere el
resultado para esto tomamos en cuenta
que en un kilómetro hay 1000 metros es
decir un kilómetro
es equivalente a mil metros otra manera
de verlo es que esto estamos
multiplicando lo por uno un kilómetro es
igual a 1000 metros
así es que esto equivale a uno y aquí
viene lo bueno aquí tenemos que estos
metros se cancelan con estos metros
18000 entre 1000 es igual a 18 y las
únicas unidades que nos quedan son
kilómetros 18 kilómetros y con esto
concluimos hemos expresado nuestra
distancia en vez de metros en kilómetros